moraliser un bon noël page 15 joseph mon
chien fidèle
jaugeant les mots
[Musique]
jobourg éléments
oh
j'en mourrais les moeurs
mais c'est
moins le monde
[Musique]
tout pouvait voir
joël bibeau
[Musique]
josée bouchard militaire chantal où je
vends le tapin c'est ma belle
ça bouge pas je sens le puy de vie se
cherchant des yeux et du nez cet avis
sur tout
[Musique]
malema
dans ce pays paradis avons cherché à
tous les résidents
l'ogive les voisins la pente lui vas-y
tu deviens jeudi
[Musique]
jared malsin
mma
dans toute la boule à des dangers pour
donner avant ça
avez vous échangé pour nous
[Musique]
je ne peux
mais cédera pas à changer de langue
[Musique]
c'est
bonjour
j'aurais aimé ces débats